tensions and expectations are running
high with pope francis the head of the
catholic church visiting iraq
the 84 year old pontiff is on a mission
to bring peace and reconciliation
to the war-torn country including to
northern iraq where between
2014 and 2017 thousands of christians
were killed under the rule of
islamic state fanatics these days there
are still grave concerns about the
threat posed by terrorism
and by kovid 19 and the catholic church
itself is in turmoil
in many parts of the world not least
germany
so on to the point we ask pope francis
in iraq
mission impossible
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on to the point where my guests
in the studio
are journalist and filmmaker duzen tekal
who says iraq is one of many countries
where christians are being persecuted
which is why it's so important that pope
francis is traveling
to the region also with us is the author
and theologian alexander gerlach who
says
a papal visit to iraq in times of corona
is far
from wise and a warm welcome to to
baghdad born journalist amir musawi who
says the pope's meeting with the grand
ayatollah sistani
will be a turning point in the christian
muslim
dialogue interesting fascinating indeed
thank you all three for being here today
and amir i would like to begin with you
i mentioned your baghdad born you grew
up in baghdad the pope is visiting iraq
what does it mean for the iraqi people
well peter i think iraqis wait waited
that
visited since long long time i think if
you go
back to the 2000 i think the last pope
johannes paulus ii tried also to travel
to iraq to visit also ur
south of iraq but because of the
political situation
under the saddam era it was not possible
why have they been waiting so long for a
christian leader to come to their
country
the the weight of his spiritual weight
that he's present in the worldwide and
also the
the lessons that he giving not just for
the the ordinary people but also all
for the politician leaders worldwide i
think this is
very important for them from one side
from other side
they say iraq is one of the most
important
lands for the christianities and also
for islam and
jewish that's why this is the the time
the beginning ground zero
to come again to the understanding
between people from this that religions
and also because iraq was um devastating
the last 30
40 years suffering from violence
suffering from
wars sanctions and so on and i think
they described as a martyred country
absolutely and and his visiting give
iraq
and iraqis a sign of the light in the
end of the tunnel
give them hope give them a new start
to begin to understand each other to
present their self
not as a country with devastating and
war but also
a country with hopes with potential of
the human being
okay alexander golov that's what it
means for the iraqi people what does it
mean for the pope
well i feel the the pope as you
indicated already army has been there's
a long strain of popes who wanted to see
that land uh this holy land for the
three monarchistic religions
however i would say we have seen last
year photos or pictures of saint peter's
square abundant
uh the carbine mecca being abandoned at
the holy sites in jerusalem because of
the
of the pandemic and you see like world
leaders meeting for their summits online
so i'm sure it's not the same like while
you peruse the streets of iraq
where yeah to see the people and greet
them however
this is not like an opportune time to go
and assemble and
create mass assemblies of people in the
time of a global pandemic
what's all this going to feel like dusan
on the ground at the moment in iraq you
know the country very very well it's
complexities and it's conflict
i think it's a big sign for all
religious minorities not just for the
christian people
especially for example for the yazidi
people and
of course right now we have an awful
situation
with people who suffered
what isis has done to them so in 2014
when isis came into the christian yazidi
villages
uh and and approved in northern iraq
where many uh people are living
christian people and also yazidi people
um they have still suffered till today
so we are
talking about 2800 women
yazidi women who are still in the hands
of isis
and they don't want to be connected
always with what happened to them they
want hope they want justice
and they want the world to know what
exactly happened to them and i think
this could be a big sign uh the first
time
that the pope is traveling to iraq and
shows right like you said before
and solidarity and also uh maybe more
hope for the population
who's uh still there and in need um are
people going to be
uh are they are people in their minds
and in their hearts really going to be
open to the spiritual message that pope
francis brings with him i think when you
don't have any other options you have to
so for example we have a women
empowerment center in iraq
and the first time when we started to
create a center
we said it must be multi-ethnical and
multi-religious
because of the fact of reconciliation
but that was very challenging but i
think
to come together means to speak together
and this kind of hope is
strongly needed but it's not the only
thing
of course we the people there need
justice
and they want to know how their people
have been killed
where their bones of their parents are
you already talked about kojo so
we are talking about a modern genocide
in the 21st century
and it's still going on and what
happened in kocho
is unspeechable for example just to
explain
for our viewers what did happen um i
think
this was the place where isis showed
how horrible the acts
were and for example all men
from kocho nearly have been killed and
all women to 30 years old for example
nadia murad
who is one of the famous popular women
who was in the hands of isis
have been slaved and solved at the slave
markets in
in mosul and all children which is very
important as well
have been sold as child soldiers so all
the pictures which all of us saw
are from kocho and i think this was a
big
deep pain which is still there
and there are many yazidis who are also
very happy that the pope is coming and
of course the people are hoping the
religious minority that could be
assigned which
help them maybe i mean how well prepared
is iraq for this visit
well the whole state with its
abilities security ability abilities and
also
logistics has been now in a stand by
waiting to to um to receive the pope and
this
um extraordinary visit of uh iraq
i think the security issue is one of the
important point
but also are you confident that things
are going to go well yes
of course i think um iraqis could manage
that i think there is a long discussion
has been
been happened between the pope's guards
and also iraqi securities and many
visiting have been happened and also the
the white house is going to move
but it is the question is not this the
question what are
the politician in iraq is going to do
with that visit
with the with the result of that visit
it is just
a small a good uh uh
idea and all good words or or it is
after the words there is
going to be something action in the
ground just to come
together just to concentrate and
focusing to rebuild the country
this is the big question that many
iraqis are now asking themselves
well before we address that question
alexander you are somebody who who's
questioned the wisdom of the visit a
little bit
yeah so as i indicated earlier i feel
it's like maybe
while world leaders do like their their
summits like online
and certainly it's not the same uh but i
but i feel like you know be they uh
travel for pleasure and vacation or
being a pilgrimage it's now not
necessarily the time to do that
there's this uh story that's been going
around and we just have to touch on it
just a little bit there's
there's been the suggestion that uh the
pope's delegation the media delegation
they're all going to be
inoculated against the uh against the
coronavirus
but the local people in iraq are not you
know how how
that looks bad yes i think so of course
it looks bad and we have to be careful
and take care of all people in the world
not just the pope's pope and his
delegation for example
so i think that must be very important
how to deal with that
and to bring hope of course is something
very
important but how is also a question in
times of corona pandemic i talked with
uh
whether one of the cardinals is
responsible
cardinal albert he's iraqi from iraqi
iraqi
church he's responsible to manage and
logistic yesterday i talked to me he
told me
ex the popes himself also wish
just to see that procedures to
be a one and a half meter between the
people
he want also to send that message i am
here
not to bring you a a dangerous but i'm
here to give you hope and please keep
careful of your healthy and this is the
procedure is going to see it
i think tomorrow in the footage that we
are going to see tomorrow
it's hyper important because we have
seen several like religious
gatherings that in germany too like that
led to an outbreak
because if you receive communion or
whatever it's going to be if it's a mass
there will be communion so people will
be like very close to
together so that could be like so i'm
happy to hear that the vatican is very
cautious about this
well what the bible teaches us says pope
francis
is that we must act tirelessly as
peacemakers and that means that we
should
especially strive for reconciliation
between the religion here's a short
report
the pope has a message for the arab
muslim world as well religions want
peace it's others who want war
francis traveled to egypt in 2017.
in cairo he met with grand imam ahmed
el-tayeb
who is considered an important figure in
sunni islam
pope francis wanted to engage muslims as
part of his initiative to promote
worldwide brotherhood and peaceful
coexistence
two years later francis became the first
pope to set foot on the arabian
peninsula
once again he met with grand imam
el-tayab and abu dhabi
their shared message faith lets us see
in others
the brothers or sisters we must love and
support
both however received sharp criticism
from religious hardliners for this
convergence
which is also sealed in writing
other stops on his travels in the
service of world peace include morocco
and now iraq despite the challenges
the pope wants to carry his message of
religious brotherhood to the country
where all three major monotheistic
religions
have their roots is the pope's
reconciliation mission
more than just symbolic politics
you say alexander is it more than
symbolic polar politics is there much
more to it than that
we saw quite some junk from from egypt i
lived in egypt like quite 18 years ago
and studied it alaska where this
gentleman is the grand
imam and there as much as in the vatican
you have like for decades now
um the the wish and the longing for more
reconciliation more
conversation if you will and that's an
interesting thing because in the past i
feel religious leaders were very much
proud to just
you know make their flock being more
radicalized whereas nowadays we see that
religious leaders try to like foster
world peace and understanding whereas
other like
alternative let's say like terrorist
groups or radical groups within
the church or other religions try to
undermine this effort
so of course the church having like now
five decades since the second vatican
council of
inter-religious dialogue and having this
dialogue for instance with al-assad
university but also institutions in iran
i'm
i'm aware that is of course more than
just a symbol that rests on decades of
like mutual
you know um understanding yeah does that
speak to you susan
i think it have to be more than a simple
because
there are so much challenges uh
especially for the minorities
in this country that the people have a
big hope that that could be more than
simple politics
and it's a huge burden for the pope of
course it is and it's not just
that day which will make the change of
course not
but i think in a region where people who
are
um belong to minorities like the
christians
or the yazidis this is also very special
because we are still talking about the
fact that they don't have the same
rights we are talking about an
ongoing genocide we are talking about
the fear
instead of what is happening in the
future so we are we are talking about
three 40 million christians who are
under threatened worldwide
and iraq in the places um
i think on the 11th side okay which
threatened the christian
minority and um i think this
visit could be something to make clear
this is the country of muslims
christians and all religious minorities
and
therefore i think it's more than a
symbol
the majority muslim population in iraq
has looked on
and seen terrible things happening to
the minority christian population
shocking shocking things
i don't need to quote all the figures
we're all familiar with the figures
uh what what why
is there a sense that the muslim
population is open to the message that
the pope is bringing with him
i think the question could be
are they open each other from both sides
for
each of other for the messages this is
the most important question
i think it's make no sense just to send
a message to the
al-azhar and as are just receiving i
think
it is a open communication get and take
um and i think when the pope is going to
meet
uh italia this is
this is so much hinges on this meeting
exactly exactly this is a i call it a
turning
point of the discussion between islamic
and christian
words because he's going to meet a
different
caliber of the spiritual figure
i think when we saw in the er in your uh
report that he met man many islamic
figures in egypt and in morocco in
emirates
and it was um it was a big action and
there is a protocol and it is a luxury
uh meeting he's going to meet up a man
an
old man in a small small house with a
small
a small way that is i understand you
know what you're talking about you have
been to this small house
the ayatollah rents as far as i
understand in najaf very
very modest very unpretentious
absolutely and he's very simple man
and he's not able he don't want to meet
the politician because he
he believed that the the state could be
managed
with the politicians this is their job
my job is a spiritual way
to send a spiritual messages for the
people that's why
as our generally man or person not as a
journalist
or a politician i can visit him but if i
would be a prime minister
i think i will not have the chance but
to meet the popes
himself together with ayatollah's islami
uh
will give the discussion another another
spirit let me give you a small question
a
small idea about that when islamic state
got control over mosul
sistani called many iraqis most of them
sunni and shia
muslims to fight against islamic state
to sir
to serve um to save the holy places in
mosul
but there is no holy places in mosul for
shia or for the sunnis most of them is
for the chircian
and they liberate that churches
eyewitness
i've been embedded with the iraqi army
and i witnessed many muslims
uh taking the the cries of the church
and
bring it back who did liberate the
yazidis
areas from culture for example
that was the muslims they
they they followed the call of italia
and he say this you are a part of
of me of us and we are part of you
i think the this is the basis what the
discussion is going to be between the
pope
and allah sustani and it is very
important for us for nowadays
and of course we need solutions uh by
the way because isis is still there and
we have a make
have to make a big difference between
islamistic terrorism
and muslims of course and i think
the reconciliation is very important in
that cases
and the place where the pope will speak
in mosul is a very important one because
not far from that was the
mosque for example where al-baghdadi
called out the caliphate
so we all know how important these
pictures
have been used in a bad way so therefore
we need new pictures from this region
and of course also the iraqi population
and the political leaders have to make
clear
uh that they are willing to do more
for minorities i think how
how army now described the ayatollah
that's very resembling like the
character of the pope himself who is
like uh
that's i wouldn't say a simple man but
it's just like a man down to earth
that's maybe like he's also not like a
theologian let's say like ratzinger was
like he's just more like a parish priest
like taking care of the people like his
flock
and so i feel that seems to be like if
they meet on these on this
level and not on a super intellectual
level which could also be very
intriguing in
a way exactly but it seems like those
two have a similar personality and that
that that
makes hope for a good outcome of this
conversation no sense at all that
because of i i mentioned at the top of
the show that the catholic church in
many countries around the world is in a
period of
transition and often very divided at
this point in time does that have any
impact on the on the pope's credibility
as a spiritual leader
you've been quite critical in the past i
mean look i'm not person i mean i'm
actually not
that critical on the pope as a person
himself it's more like the structures
within the church that have
led to the biggest crisis since the
reformation age for the catholic church
this might not be like playing as much
as a role in a country where
christianity especially catholics roman
catholics are super minority
but you see like that there's a child
abuse scandal be it in new zealand or
poland or mexico or canada
has the same patterns hence i believe
the church has to change some of their
structures in order to
to survive the century and become
actually in alliance with the moral
teachings they spread
i think to be honest i understand that
discussion in europe and all this
critic uh but it it has nothing uh
in iraq as you said in iraq it is no one
talk about that at all
because the most important message that
the pope is going to visit us
we should welcome him we should invest
this visit
to send this message for the rest of the
war that we are here we want to rebuild
we want to send up
a positive signal so dustin is it is it
going to be a mission
is it a mission impossible was this was
the wording i used at the top or is it
going to be
is it going to be a mission accomplished
what are you hoping to see at the end of
this
very strenuous visit where there's huge
expectations
i think we need new
pictures because we know how
how strong pictures of enemies are
because
this is always the first step to war in
genocide
and and therefore i think we need new
narratives and
therefore this um trip from the pope
could be
very interesting and the question will
be
what iraq is doing after that and
also how the civil society is moving and
on the other hand of course the catholic
church and the whole
pope have still um own problems
uh in for example with this image
child abuse the rule of women so there
are a lot of
challenges of course but i think the
same like you that
that will not be the question in iraq
when he will
visit it there will be also like
hardliners on the catholic side who were
like
against as a photo with the grand imam
or with the ayatollah they don't like
this under
the predecessor of francis uh benedict
the pontificial council for
inter-religious dialogue
was made the subdivision of the culture
department because the hardliners took
over and said no no we don't want to
have any resemblance that it seems like
all religions were equal
so you see like this is even in the
catholic church like the dialogue it's
not like that everyone is like excited
in the vatican about this pope's
endeavors hence i mean
i have to say this is quite brave of him
to just to
pursue that and it's not just religious
history it's
also political because we want to show
and
make clear that christian minorities
must be secure at this regions and the
fact that they are not
is sad enough but the question will be
how to make it possible that christian
and yazidi living in the future is still
possible in this region how it was
many many years before i think he's not
going to be
to bring us a big
changing in the ground directly um
i think it is a ongoing process
whether it is in politician uh question
how to secure
secure the minorities how how to rebuild
the country
or but the main important point how to
bring
the human beings together under the base
of the respect from each side
and also accept each other and also of
the
brotherhood um how to communicate with
with other person with with other faith
other religion
uh in a in a in a human way
to respect the law that we made
i think if you if i can describe the
visit of the pope
in iraq i think we built as a house we
built the walls
but his visit in iraq will bring the
roof
of that house and the finishing
is ongoing on process in such a troubled
country as iraq what makes you so
optimistic that this could be the
outcome
because the many of the muslims
community
understood that the the way that the
extremism
that is present it is not
of their faith it's not the way of the
life that they wish
they try it and they see it they live it
themselves especially the sunni minority
uh the sunni population in iraq
and they understood in the end of the
time this is not
the life that we want to that's why i'm
quite sure
that that majority will not accept the
extremism
that's why they are going to engage with
this
with this discussion of the acceptance
okay
time's over thank you very very much for
those final words i hope your optimism
uh is proved it is vindicated by this
weekend's event we've been talking about
the pope
in uh in iraq uh thanks very much for
joining us i hope we've given you plenty
of food for thought if we have come back
next time round until then bye bye
and cheers
[Music]
so
you